Good morning John, it's Friday.
You're an author, you love books, I love books
too.
I read a lot of 'em, though apparently I am
mildly dyslexic enough that I read at the
level of third grader according to this Staples
test.
But listen, we've been making books for thousands
of years now, so you'd think that we'd've
perfected the process, and yet I HAVE SOME
THINGS that I would like to discuss with publishing
companies.
So I love to spend time at bookstores, and
to figure out what I want, I read the reviews,
and I read the blurbs, and also I read the
description.
WHY would you put a major spoiler in the description
on the back of the book?!
I don't want to be halfway through a book
and the thing that I know is going to happen
hasn't happened yet 'cause I read it on the
thing that's like two paragraphs!
Is it so hard to keep a spoiler out of that?!
Why would you do that!?
Interestingly, Looking for Alaska does not
do this, but, in one edition that I noticed—so
there's the author bio on the back page, and
it's like "Looking for Alaska was written
by John Green, who likes to make candy canes
and lollipops and lives with his puppy in
Indianapolis"—that's what it says, right?—if
you turn to that page to read about the author,
which you might want to do before you read
the book, on the facing page there's a, like
a question for, you know, reader questions
for like if it's taught in a school or something,
and the—the question is: "Do you think that
SPOILER SPOILER was a SPOILER or a SPOILER?"
Think about this stuff!
Okay, also, if a book is part of a series,
please just let me know.
On the cover, or the inside flap, just like
five words.
"This is the second book in the Sword of Butts
trilogy," so I KNOW.
Do it like graphic novels do it, just put
a little number on the bottom that—it so—it's
great.
There's nothing wrong with EXCEPT WHEN YOU
DO THIS!
NEVER, EVER!
THAT'S THE WORST THING ON MY BOOKSHELF!
They're all first editions!
It's not even from a different edition!
They just made a mistake!
And I hate it so much!
Anyway, covers.
You can't judge a book by 'em, but don't,
if it's like a really high quality fantasy
epic, I don't want to see a half-naked guy
on a horse with a sword.
I'm not gonna believe that it's a good book
if there's a half-naked guy on a sword with
a horse!
On a sword with a horse?
I take it back.
If there's a half-naked guy on a sword, then
I'll probably buy that book.
Decapitated YA fiction ladies?
Stop.
We've had enough.
Books that look like they're Twilight but
aren't Twilight?
No, why would you do that?
Okay, here's another thing.
This is the, The Ocean at the End of the Lane,
amazing book.
This — I don't know if you can see this,
let, let's get in here.
This is the, your deckled edge, where it's
not, it's not, uh, flat.
Why?
This makes it harder to read the book!
And it's always in books that are, like, fancier
and more expensive.
So it must cost more.
If you're paying more for something that makes
something less functional, maybe not do it.
It's like during those years when pants got
really expensive if they had pre-made holes
in them.
I can make my own pant holes, thank you.
Also, just don't lie to me.
This is The Casual Vacancy by J.K.
Rowling, and it says on the back "The big
novel about a small town that became a #1
worldwide bestseller."
That is a little misleading.
"It overcame insurmountable odds to become
this popular book!"
It's written by the eleventh most popular
author of all time.
It might become a number one bestseller.
I don't think anybody was surprised.
Books are nice, but they're not a perfect
format.
I mean, you have to charge the battery all
the time, there's all those annoying pop-up
advertisements, pre-rolls.
What I'm basically saying is THIS IS A FAR
SUPERIOR MEDIA TO MOST OF THEM.
Except for Vlogbrothers videos, which are
the best of all the media.
By pinnacling it!
This is the Cadillac of the ultimate!
Not penultimate, which does not mean the same
thing, which I learned while I was giving
an oral presentation and somebody laughed
at me.
So.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday!
The first episode of The Art Assignment is.
On.
Line.
Right.
Now.!Go to youtube.com/theartassignment and
watch it.
The Yeti has a Youtube channel.
Who would have guessed?